vsauce kevin here with the ultimate
representation of
good and evil an epic battle of morality
that has raged on game boards across the
globe for
over 2 000 years
snakes and ladders wait
snakes and ladders that's nothing but a
really
simple kids game right wrong while the
rules
are simple the math psychology and
hidden spiritual lessons are
surprisingly complex so to highlight
that unique combination in a visual way
i commissioned an intricate version of
the game that harnesses
electricity to demonstrate the
unpredictable
gameplay the circuit that's made as we
play will not only
show the path to victory but will also
reveal the meaning of life
sort of this custom game board was
created by engineering youtube wizard
alan
pan the winner of this game of snakes
and ladders will trigger
this mystery box to do something
i i seriously 100 percent do not know
what's inside this box or what will
happen when the first player reaches
the final square but we're about to find
out
together i do know that it's powered by
16
double a batteries alan put it together
in an afternoon and he promised me he
promised that it will not burn down
my house so that's good
here's how it works allen 3d printed
red and yellow game pieces that contain
about 50 feet of stainless steel
conductive thread he's put a nail
juncture at every snake's head and tail
on every ladder's top and bottom and at
the end of each row
on the board i'll start by hooking up
both
game pieces to this bolt and tightening
this nut down on it
i'll be red and you will be yellow and
as we play i'll wrap the steel
thread around these junctures which will
weave a path
up ladders and down snakes to show a
trail
of each player's movement on the game
board here's the important part
when the winning players piece touches a
node
on the final square that will complete a
circuit to the
battery-powered mystery box and whatever
this
thing does it will
do now let's climb some ladders and
slide down some snakes
or shoots you probably know this game as
shoots and ladders since that's the name
milton bradley gave it in 1943 when it
was imported to the u.s
and sold for 50 cents i guess they
thought snakes were scary
and weird which they are but the game
actually goes back
much much further than your grandpa joe
it actually originated in india in about
the 2nd century bc
and was meant to teach children the
importance of
karma and comma existences push
and pull between one's destiny and the
actions that
disrupt the path to that destiny
the gameplay is obviously very simple
the two players started at square
one which may actually be where we get
the phrase
starting at square one and then roll a
die
four the player then moves that number
of spaces
if you land at the bottom of a ladder
then you get to climb the ladder to that
space
if you land at the head of a snake then
you have to slide backwards
down to the snake's tail and if there's
nothing on the space then it's the other
player's turn
the first player to get to the final
100th space
wins that's it that's the game in the
official rules you need
an exact role to reach the 100th space
so like if you're two spaces away you
need to roll
a two to win but that can get pretty
tedious most people just call it a win
when you roll at least
high enough to get to the final space
and i'll do the same
boards historically labeled ladders that
advance your piece
with good virtuous actions like
generosity or
learning conversely snakes were depicted
along with vices such as
greed or gluttony navigate the snakes
and ladders successfully and the winner
escapes
samsara life's cycle of death and
rebirth
to reach moksha or salvation who knew a
game
literally recommended for
three-year-olds was this
profound just looking at this board i
can see
that snakes are a lot worse than the
ladders
are beneficial but how much worse
we can figure out the breakdown of this
board's 10 ladders and
11 snakes from 4 to 16 is a
plus 12. 12 to 33 is a plus 21
49 to 51 plus two not much of a help
there
and 88 to 92 is a plus
four all right snakes twenty one two
three
that's a minus eighteen fifty to eleven
minus thirty nine ninety three
to twenty five minus sixty eight
it's like falling down a well and 99 to
58 minus 41. all right
so the advantage of ladders we're
looking at 118
divided by 10 equals plus
11.8 per ladder and for snakes we're
looking at
388 divided by 11
equals minus 35.27
per snake it's almost exactly three
times
worse to land on a snake than it is
beneficial to land on a ladder
and there's an additional snake in there
just to make it tougher because
why not and this whole thing is probably
just random no
it's not an integral message of this
game
is that it's harder to follow a path
of good than it is to follow a
path of bad it's just easier to
slide down into bad choices and bad
habits than it is to
lift yourself up with virtuous deeds
and as subtle as the game's hidden moral
lessons may be
get alone of the unseen mathematical
operation
this absolutely ancient board game is
actually a 101 state absorbing markov
chain
a series of events that depends on the
state of the
prior event which we first explored in
parando's paradox
that could theoretically go on forever
especially when you've got so many
punishing snakes
and if you want to make absolutely sure
the next time you're playing this with
your five-year-old sister sally that it
doesn't last
nine hours well you can't i mean it's
not
likely that a game will last the rest of
your lives but with just the right
combination of roles and
snakes it actually could because
snakes and ladders isn't a game of skill
there's nothing you can do to speed up a
win and there's no mistake that you can
make to
lose all you can do is roll and
see what happens okay this is taking a
while what if i
really really want to know when this
game will
end i can use board states and random
roles to run
a monte carlo simulation that gives us
the most common length of our
snakes and ladders game and the odds of
any given length
two three four four four yes
we are close one two three
four for you one two
three four all right look uh until this
moment i had
left this battery out for a reason i was
worried that i don't know i would have
messed something up and then this thing
would have done something and then i
wouldn't have been able to put
whatever happens back in here so the
fact is we're at 98
and it's my turn and as long as i don't
roll a one
it is the actual moment of truth i've
reached the end of the board i've
successfully
ascended ladders and overcome the
pitfalls of
evil snakes so i'm gonna put this
battery in now
is fully charged
as they say it is lit
okay i'm gonna move everything so that
you get the best possible look
at whatever is about to happen next
[Music]
don't roll the one don't roll a one
don't roll a one
don't roll a one
okay four all right
oh how am i so nervous about this
here we go
[Laughter]
it was actual oh my gosh there's actual
snakes
well not actual snakes but spring
bloated snakes
[Laughter]
the gearing up of it was actually almost
as scary
as the exploding snakes themselves
snakes and ladders is a remarkable
combination of mathematics and human
psychology that was invented
centuries before the stochastic
techniques needed to analyze it were
known
let alone two board game designers think
about it a game
intended for children needs to average
just the right length
too short and it's not interesting
enough too long and
it gets boring snakes and ladders nailed
this
so perfectly that thousands of years
later kids are still
growing up playing the game and that
isn't an accident
billions of people across 100
generations have played
snakes and ladders without even
considering the
deep story of numbers morality and
the essence of human existence buried
below its childish facade
in describing the hindu board game lila
which is a 72 space
version of snakes and ladders harish
jahari said
there is really only one game
the game in which each of us is a player
acting out his role and while
sometimes in life we land on ladders
that
launch us ahead and other times we step
on snakes that slide us back you gotta
just
pick up the die and give it another roll
because the game goes on until
eventually you reach your goal
whether that's reaching nirvana or
triggering a mystery box of
springy snakes and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]